we were trying to make andrew appealing
to a certain type of audience you know
these democratic donors
and they already had 29 other options
and we were doing the impossible and we
were
out of left field all these things
instead of bringing andrew to a certain
type of audience
we need to find the audience that likes
our certain type of candidate we need to
bring
we need to find the audience that
already loves who andrew is and
the way we found them um
was it started with podcasts well in a
way it brings us back to this podcast
man
it's one reason why i love this podcast
so much
uh podcasts really were our genesis
our birthing ground like the way we
developed
any kind of a following this podcast has
been
a real source of strength and comfort
and learning and community for me uh
there have been any number of times when
i had a conversation with someone
and it became a chapter in a book or a
policy
in some cases or
like a new line of thinking and argument
that i make this podcast
many many times has been an environment
where
i would realize something for the first
time because i was saying it out loud to
[Music]
someone
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks this is your
co-host zach grauman i'm
on with andrew today and on today's
episode
we take some time to reflect because
over the past six months there's been as
you many of you have known who stayed
loyal kept listing this there's been an
elephant in the room that we have not
talked about and that is the office that
andrew has been running for
uh here in new york city and we take
some time to talk
about how we got here starting with
how i met andrew and started working
with him in 2017 how he dropped out of
the presidential race how we started
humanity forward and why we wanted
to save our home and tomorrow
is election day in new york city
and we take some time and get all
emotional talk about
where we've been but more importantly
win lose or draw
the bigger picture about what we're
doing because we're in a fight
fight to save this country the cavalry's
not coming we
are the cavalry and win loser draw on
election day
our journey is just getting started and
i want to thank you guys for listening
and i hope you enjoyed this conversation
with andrew and i i think a lot of you
will resonate with it um because you've
been on this journey with us for
a couple years now so tuning guys andrew
and i are doing a bit of reflection
right now
on yang speaks
[Music]
[Applause]
and now uh i welcome to yank speaks
a regular my brother zach graumann and
so this isn't really uh like
this usually isn't as zack as guest um
i'm kind of
gonna be my own guest a little bit or me
and zach are going to
reflect uh on the last
two and a half to three years a little
bit uh first i want to thank everyone
who's listening right now
for listening to this podcast i know
over the last number of months you've
been like isn't yang running for mayor
why is he not talking so much about
running for mayor what's going on like
it's a little bit like i compare it to a
tv show
where all of a sudden it became just
like one episode installments
you know what i mean like like sometimes
you have these shows where there's like
an elaborate plot
line and it's like the whole season long
and then the plot
resolves and there's like a big bad at
the end and then other times it's just
like self-contained episodes
you just watch one like a law order
thing where you don't need to have
watched any of the other law orders
to know what's going on and i i and i
feel like yang speaks definitely became
very
isolated episode uh where
uh you know we would talk about
something but it didn't seem to
fit within the certainly the context of
my my current run um and so i wanted to
first say thank you to everyone
um because uh it's been an awesome
time and i'm just so grateful to
everyone who's
born with us uh throughout the last
number of weeks and months i hope you've
enjoyed it i mean we've had like some
incredible
guests and some incredible conversations
um
yeah and i mean i i've enjoyed it i've
said to zach
many times where this podcast has been a
form of comfort
and even therapy for me i don't know if
people sense that at all
and so i called zach on here so that we
could reflect a little bit
on the big picture arc of where we
started
back in let's call it beginning of 2018.
when do you put as the start
zach of our adventure together
running for president so i got i took a
number of months i actually tried to
like find the exact dates on this
um because i've been um i've been
writing a book
on the kind of this journey which is fun
actually everyone
zach has been writing a book and i have
read
i have read excerpts from it and it's
awesome uh evelyn has read both
uh parts of his book and the parts of my
book that's coming out later this year
and evelyn prefers zach's book i just
want everyone to know that
that's uh mine's more about like the
journey right and like the roller
coaster yours is more about like solving
problems and
um where we go and things like that
um so you can see why evelyn prefers
accidents so zach tell us about
tell us about uh the book the journey
and when when did you say the journey
began
so um that's actually the number one
question i get andrew's like how'd you
be
andrew so i knew andrew from
so i knew andrew from my daisy ubs i was
helping rich people give money to
charity
and they loved andrew they loved venture
for america andrew was
a rock star in the social
entrepreneurship space now that is a
tiny space to play in
um but we would have him and come to our
like client events all the time
i'd seen him speak on panels and cret
and was always very great um
fantastic at them um like his humor
would come through that kind of thing
andrew yang panel star
for sure i'll never actually this is
funny yes this is so funny do you
remember this okay i want to set this up
so this is not in the book but um
you did a panel at we used to do these
um basically billionaire kids events
like if you're super wealthy and you
bring your kids like how do you inherit
like 100 million
types of events and we'd always do
something like a philanthropy day
and you did a panel with a guy named
adam braun
um and if you wanted to pick like draw
like the perfect
like white boy stud it's probably adam
braun he's like yours quite strongly
good looking
ivy educated rich like started this
non-profit
and he tells this he tells this story of
this organization at the time called
pencils of promise
and he tells his story about how he goes
to africa and he asks a kid like what do
you want most in the world
um and he said a pencil and it's like
this heartbreaking story and he's
telling this in the context of saying
like my whole life my parents had told
me like bronzer special
bronzer special like and he knew it in
his heart when it happened until
and there's not like a dry eye in the
room like everybody's like oh my god
adam
and then it's like and then the
moderator's like okay andrew your turn
and he's just like
andrew you go yeah you know my parents
told me the exact opposite actually
they're like yang you're not special
they're like go to law school do
something traditional like work for a
law firm like you're boring and he's
like you're my non-profit like
it's like oh it's teach for america from
entrepreneurs let's call it venture for
america like nothing about this was
special in my head and the room just
lost it um that was my first like debate
experience theoretically of andrew yang
without knowing it that was probably
2016
on my hat 2015. and i have to say
coming to those events was always a
treat because the environments were
always
super nice and the food was good and
like you know
like sometimes there was like you know
that there there was a celebrity or
entertainer yeah one of the kids
they were fun um now so so zach and i
knew each other through that
for uh a while so it's true when someone
says like how did you meet andrew like
you would have to backtrack to
maybe were you in 2015. i met you and so
i asked you to be
my roommate actually worked for you
worked for venture america joe guy
um and he was like you have to go joe
guy isn't a great guy
joe guy mr knight mr guy um
but he was like you got to meet andrew
you guys are two forces of nature to
actually tell direct words
um and i asked andrew to be on my board
of my nonprofit and andrew's like i love
this idea sure how can i help i'll be on
your board great
um there's a classic andrew like yeah if
i can if my name can be helpful
which it was to get more people more
legitimacy anyway so i had heard long
story short i heard andrew's
your shtick like hundreds of times and i
went to this dinner and andrew
it was
it was april i think of 2017
is like the timing of there wow it's
somewhere in like earth like late
no it's somewhere in that mid-2017 yeah
yeah that'd be right before the summer i
thought it was summer it's not
and um i went to this like jeffersonian
round
table dinner i used to go to all the
time i was like very pretentious like 15
people
meant to be on a topic and this was on
the future of work
and i was curious about this topic and i
go and i got the list of the roster and
i'm like oh there's gonna be all these
cool people here i'm excited
and i go to this like restaurant i think
in the west village or somewhere
downtown
like private room and who parachutes in
andrew yang parachutes in
and i remember being pissed i mean like
damn it i've heard your spiel
a hundred thousand times where you're
like hey like we got all the smart minds
in the world doing six things in six
places we need to get them
out of like the new yorks and san
francisco and the world and get them to
detroit and cleveland it's in a great
it's a great pitch but i was hoping to
learn something
and yang comes in and just drops this
bomb like takes over the room and drops
what i eventually called like the
automation bomb which was like a working
version of the war on normal people
like why donald trump got elected here
all the jobs in the united states
half of them are going away and then in
the middle
in this room after he's got the whole
room like captivated
and he's like and i'm running for
president united states
and it was like you could hear a pin
drop it was like
president president of the country like
of america
uh and uh how we got connected
afterwards i was like well andrew i was
looking at i just paid off student loans
i was like looking to
leave ubs um and i was like hey andrew
i'll help and you're like great you can
manage your campaign something like that
well because i knew
because i knew you were very very strong
uh you know you were a builder you were
a doer
i mentally thought to myself uh like you
know i need to make sure that zach is
into this
um because he elevates our chances of
impact and success
uh dramatically immeasurably um and so
this let's call this like spring 2017 uh
i mentally was
like super pumped about it and then i
resolved then to try and
uh update you periodically and keep you
updated so that the main thing i was
working on at that point
was a manuscript for the book uh and so
i would just send you pages
yeah i got coffee and vote
uh this is your book we got coffee this
is one of the rare times you get to go
behind you and pull the book
and i get coffee with andrew like two
weeks later and he sits across and he
slides me this book raising the floor by
andy stern he's like first of all
read that and then this is like this is
what sold me on universal basic income
and the second thing i asked i actually
whole bunch of questions i don't
remember this i was like
jamie skelton's in the closet you're
like no i'm boring i go like it was
right around like this is the height of
me too it was like just starting i was
like you're not gonna please i'm not
doing this you're getting me well
what's funny too is like you know exact
exact new people i'd worked with i think
we could
check and be like hey does this andrew
have any of that accessory they were
like no
i did a lot of research that and then i
was like well what's your plan
you know i could help with money i'll
always hustle the fundraiser like what's
the plan of money and the path here and
you
you pulled up the new york times um this
was so pression was
stuck with me you pulled up the new york
times i think it was new york time i
didn't watch the post but i think it was
new york times infographic
on the republican primary and how much
money they raised and how they
performed and you said yeah and you said
um
you're like what do you think the
democratic primary field's gonna look
like and i'm not giving this that much
thought i was like i guess probably
pretty crowded and i can't really think
of a front runner like yeah
like it's gonna look like the
republicans there's gonna be a ton of
people running
and so i just need elaine to get my
message out and be considered serious
and then he's like now everybody thinks
you gotta raise billions of dollars in
politics but
the reality is republicans do that
because they can get super pac money
but i've looked at what these clowns i
think was i don't know the exact word
but some of these guys on the republican
side had raised
and it was like it was like huckabee
uh carly fiorina a couple named ben
carson there were a couple names
that were christie that were yeah
christy that were big names that it only
raised like
one to three million dollars if i recall
and you're like i can raise that
um and like we can do like that is a
feasible number to be a serious
contender
and i remember i don't know if i said
this number to you but i i think i said
this to myself i was like i can raise at
least 29.
um and and 20 million would have put me
in like
fairly serious contender category we
ended up raising 40.
uh but i i in my mind's i don't know if
i ever said this to you out loud zach
but i was like
you know like i had an internal goal i
was like we can raise 20 mil
for like such a ridiculous goal
presidential
presidential it turns out i was a little
bit cocky and unrealistic because
then when we got into it like you know
it was actually very difficult to raise
um the first year was rough yeah like
you're like raised four mil
much less like 20 mil though we did
eventually get to 40 with
a bunch of escape velocity and thank you
everyone listening to this i have a
feeling you probably contributed to that
40 million so thank you thank you thank
you
uh super super grateful but yeah i
showed you that infographic i was like
look
this democratic primary is going to be a
zoo they're going to be over a dozen
candidates like we just need to raise uh
you know x million dollars to be able to
to fund an operation
and compete yep i'll i'll fast forward a
little bit but you in the
when we finally got in office this is
probably may i think either april may of
20 uh
18 yeah um you
we were like struck the first year was
really hard to raise money and you were
there
and you were they said like you know
zach i got to say zach i never i never
told you this but this this was like a
big thing for me and you can actually
get into this maybe
so so the timeline is you and i do this
thing in spring 2017
i'm like sending you stuff being like
hey man it's great it's great it's great
i filed the paperwork for the
presidential campaign in november 2017
which obviously no one notices or cares
no one cares
all the time not yet sorry but i got i
got the article in the times february
2018
so there were there was a four-month
period or so when i was uh building and
uh
you know like uh coming up with policies
and
like graphics and like all of uh this
kind of stuff
uh email addresses and then during this
time
i i did never not tell you this i was
like there is a
you know i thought in my mind's eye i
was like there's like a 20
to 20 like to 30 chance that zach uh
realizes that joining me in this is is
very very foolhardy
yeah because so so there was like a part
of me that was like oh [ __ ] like if zach
realizes this like
that that's gonna be very difficult for
me because i can't
kind of uh you know have zach pencilled
it as the like
you know operator campaign manager um
and so every day between
when like you know we we had launched
and and before you
left ubs uh full-fledged and enjoying
the team i i had that this like
no [ __ ] i really gotta you know like
make sure that zach
actually sees the path and the light i
appreciate that and so what was your
last day
of getting paid by ubs because this was
like the period when i was like
is that really gonna leave his uh his
sweet uh
banking job to join our madcap
presidential campaign so what when was
that date
so i didn't end up leaving
my first date uh day
on the campaign i think was march 2018.
either march 1 or like middle march um i
have a date in the book
and what's the name of your book the
book is y'all called long shot
right now uh uh there's a subtitle i
can't remember and when's it coming
when's it coming out we'll do another
pod when yeah we'll do it we'll dive
into the book we give you the full-on
author treatment yeah but everyone now
like their their appetite is being
wedded they're like i'm totally it's
it's it's meant to be funny it's meant
to be all the stuff
it's like the book i think the end gang
wants to read about this i hope that's
my that's my goal um
there's a lot of stories like andrew it
is that's why someone else is
my my book is my book is not really the
book that yang gang wants to read but uh
but yours is and yeah that's what
everyone said
i think it's funny from political lens
too we'll see um but
uh so i left ubs
yeah i was like look i was like is this
real or is it not what sold me guys i
read the manuscript of the book
and i jumped out of my bed in one of the
chapters i remember calling my brother
and i was like i gotta work for him i
don't know i don't know why it just
feels right then it feels like call to
do it
and then it was like it was one of the
things like if i didn't do i'd regret it
the rest of my life
um and so like my first day let's say
it's like march 1st
2018. i never uh we were at andrew's
mom's apartment
before we got our first office and there
was what
three other people plus you uh one guy
muhan was living there
um but i remember showing up in like a
suit and i didn't wear a tie because i
thought that'd be too fun i wore like a
suit and i was like all wall street
ready
and like i got there like 8 30 i was
like man you know like maybe
8 o'clock i don't know what time it was
but it was early it was like you know um
like a morning and muhan wasn't even out
of bed yet and there was no one in this
office it was just
no one in the apartment and i was like
oh this is gonna be different man um
the apartment was full of boxes because
that's where all the boxes from his book
uh were being stored amazon boxes i was
like man
okay this is uh this is not or not in
kansas anymore
and then at one point i was like all
right zach first thing you need to do is
get us an office
yes please start because the office is
everywhere
yeah was it april one all right so we're
out of my mind
um which i which i i i loved that time
operating at my mom's i mean i was very
excited to get to the office don't get
me wrong and i knew it had to be in the
office as quickly as possible because
uh you know it would be impossible for
us to operate but also
like no self-respecting human would like
show up to my mom's apartment i think
that
we were uh yeah you couldn't host people
there
yeah yeah that's a problem so um so the
office we got
i love that office i was on 39th street
and 7th avenue
uh high ceilings wood floors you know
like it was we got a wall that everyone
signed anytime we came in we'd have them
sign it
and so that began april 2018 the big
new york times launch was february 2018
and i thought it would kick off more
than it did it didn't kick off that much
i think we were hoping for the internet
monies to start pouring in earlier
it did not no they did they they they
did not and so then we started hitting
the
the path um so i i guess i'll i'll
you know because at this point um
definitely read the book long shot
and and i have some of this stuff too in
my book that's coming out yeah there's
parker
um and i look back on 2018 now quite
fondly even though
it was very very difficult at the time
but you know like we were allowed to
do things in uh kind of in the dark like
if we had a bad day no one cared
we could screw up it didn't matter yeah
like you know and i remember
hanging out in the in the office
and then uh liam uh declined blows you
know
very very young guy who who uh we for
some reason we're taking advice from it
was pretty funny i mean like he was
really nice
because he's because he's really so hard
but he was like hey you guys should go
on a tour i forgot
well this clarified one other thing and
i appreciate you saying before like it
was like it was gonna be a home run if
we get zach and
at the time i did not think that i was
like i hope he hires me but at the end
the other times like it was very very
very difficult to hire people on this
campaign
it wasn't it was hard to get people to
pay attention to the campaign so like
i think when people talk about
you know like what we could have done
better operationally
or how we grew or that sort of thing
like
for the first year we were just taking
what we get and then eventually a spigot
went off and we were just hiring on the
fly um so it was a very it was almost
like night and day or quickly but anyway
um
it's you know we took whoever you were
you had a very strong principle which i
always appreciate if someone wants to
help
let them so you remember liam saying to
us hey guys like go on a tour
and then i was like go on a tour for who
like no one's gonna show up to this tour
this is gonna be like the lamest thing
in the world
yeah and then liam managed to convince
me where he was like no
no like you know you need images of you
uh being out there and you also need to
refine the message you need to do the
pitch over and over again you need to do
all this stuff
um and and then he he was right and so i
was like all right
let's uh let's set up a tour and then
zach like a freaking superhero was like
yes we're gonna do a tour
and then we're we're going to get this
band and then zach ended up being like
the van
bus driver uh you know like everybody's
a new yorker no one could drive
and it was just we had the worst
driving early team in the world it's
like we had maybe
five or six people and i think zach was
easily the best driver among us
i can drive but you don't want the
candidate being like the driver
so it really was zach and that band and
we'd show up and we we did that tour
like so this was the humanity first tour
uh
and you know we'd have to look in and
see what the actual locations were
but on the top of your head where do you
remember the humanity first we did i
remember this pretty
uh closely i'm trying to think so we did
cleveland not in no particular order
cleveland
chicago baltimore
detroit definitely detroit um we didn't
do cincinnati it was just cleveland i
think
no since i was later um people mad at me
for not remembering this
um we went to iowa new hampshire during
this tour too right
iowa new hampshire yep or no yep we
added and we booked it yep that's right
oh and and and you remember like was
this the tour where carly
messed up like she sent me to the wrong
airport was that was that
it was carly learned that there's two
airports in washington dc
that's the tour yeah yeah that and then
i went to the wrong one and missed the
flight and then
thus was um almost going to be late to
like my tour stop in iowa or whatever
and uh uh and carly was worried that we
were going to fire her
um but at some point i'd realized that
carly's value ad was not
uh you know booking flights and like
detail orientation it was something else
and so like when i realized that then i
was like all right then
you know that this is not her fault like
we just have her in a role that doesn't
necessarily
play to who she is um and so and
and then we somehow managed to get me
there like passed me off like a football
it was crazy i flew to another airport
and then
someone it was one of these things where
two vehicles was like a freaking sat
question where two vehicles
left from opposite sides and then like
bit in the middle and then i got dropped
off there and then
the whole thing was was pretty funny and
i i think i made it
um and i made it for an event that had
how many people do you think i mean it
was still good for us but
30 15 yeah i was going to say 24 or
something like that it was like 24 but
we we moved heaven and earth to get that
it was 24 people
i want to say in iowa and at that time
you know it felt like anything we did in
in iowa was uh was monumental
yep uh so so this is uh
2018 uh the weather was not great so it
was still
oh it was oh yeah it was right before
that aisle event was right before
thanksgiving break i remember
like the reason one of the reasons the
crowd was a little smaller or not that
it would have been that much bigger if
it wasn't but a lot of kids had left for
thanksgiving break
[Music]
okay if you've been listening to this
podcast you've heard andrew and myself
talk about our helix mattresses and
helix has started a new company called
all form they've left the bedroom
and started making sofas and they are
incredibly comfortable they look good
they're durable
they're easy to assemble i freaking love
this thing so you go online
similar to helix you take a little it's
not a quiz if you will but you kind of
customize what you want
pick the leg color pick the sofa color
shape size
and it gets shipped to you like your
mattress and it's so easy to assemble i
am terrible at assembling things and it
fit like a glove it just snapped into
place
it looks awesome and what i love about
this thing guys you can get food all
over it and it does not stain my mom
works for a high-end realtor and she
read all the product descriptions she's
like this is a high-end sofa
and it is nowhere near the price of what
traditional furniture stores will charge
you and if you don't like it
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it it's more than three freaking
months
it's freaking awesome and just like
helix they'll pick it up for you and get
rid of it if you don't like it so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
yang and all form right now is offering
20 off all orders for our listeners
at allform.com yang check it out now
allform.com
[Music]
[Applause]
so 2018 i still remember finally because
we could make mistakes in the dark
and people sometimes imagined that i
sprang out
um and was doing all of this
stuff to crowd so we were working very
very small crowds i talked to people all
the time about how
you know i felt like we were musicians
getting our start or i was like a
comedian or performer getting my start i
had like the weirdest one-man show
ever it was like you know andrew yang
and uh
give everyone money and automation and
the rest of it like you know we had this
and um and you would critique my
performance and say hey yeah i had to
beat you up all the time
yeah and so for anyone who's not who
doesn't know this zach is a very very
talented
speaker performer coach
and so it's interesting because like we
used a joke at the time i was like hey
man next time you you run i'll manage
your campaign
uh because each of us has like an
operator hat that we can put on
and each of us has like a
figurehead performer speaker you know
um like like each of us can do both
uh at least in some measure you know
um and and i said to zach all the time
it's like i miss being the operator like
i missed oh yeah
especially towards the end you're like i
just want to give me a problem to solve
please
you're like no man you just press play
he's like ah um
yeah and so what was funny is we would
do these events and then zach at some
point would give some impassioned speech
to
close or ask for money or ask for
support and zach was super excellent at
it
and zach also could tell me what i was
doing
wrong you know in a better way than
others could uh and zach also to his
genius
figured out uh like when just to let it
ride
because like having someone say hey do
this better do this better it's like not
necessarily what you need
at you know like like 10 p.m in ohio
after you
speak to 12 people or whatever
you know it's not it's not like yeah
so so zach had all these incredible uh
attributes i genuinely felt feel like
the the universe put us together to do
what we did
uh and we made a dent in the universe
that i'm incredibly proud of
when our campaign ended and i as anyone
can tell i'm obviously fast forwarding a
couple of years then if like campaign
ends
but when our campaign ended i thought to
myself like that that is probably the
best thing i'll ever do when i should
really be like happy and proud about it
i mean you know we set out on a
path together in let's call it early
2018 for the purposes of this
and then it ended um early 2020
so what we accomplished in two years was
unprecedented
unfathomable someone said to me at some
point last year he said what you did was
literally impossible
what we did was literally impossible
everybody told us it was impossible and
you know what makes me so mad man when
people today call you a celebrity
politician or these rich like
whatever like like the press will spin
you all these things like
are you kidding me do not call him us
like
we fought for every goddamn inch of the
the success because you had literally
two almost two years of like slog
like embarrassment of like going to
fundraisers that didn't raise any money
and going to talk to people that told
you you were not good
that was your favorite when we did
fundraisers that didn't raise any money
uh you know so zach and i were always
doing these back and forth about raising
raising money uh and not much was
working
and so zach would be like hey doll for
dollars and i'm trying to be like this
is awful
and then i would have my like hey tell
you what i'll have my friend hold an
event
and then uh my my friend would have an
event no one would donate so zach was
like hey this is awful
i mean we were just like going back and
forth between things that
that weren't working so well we had a
home in the office anytime someone gave
a max donation which at a time was 2700
bucks and we did not honk it very often
so that way
um until uh and there would be there
would be times too it would be like
friday and i'd be looking at our
bank account i'd be like i need to get
someone to give us 2700
before i leave like i would be
uh and and that that stuff felt familiar
to me because it's like a start-up it's
a startup grind you know like i
understood the startup grind
um what became foreign to me later was
when
i became more of like an athlete
performer um and
it was very distinct from being an
operator i had never really
seen myself like that uh you were
pushing me to be that you were like hey
become the
become the athlete become the performer
become the
the figure you know like and sometimes i
would give you a hard time too because
i'll give you one example we had this
tough conversation where
i spoke to a group of very very high
level democratic donors in new york city
um and i i did a fair job of my
presentation
um no one gave anything or wanted to
support me afterwards
and then and then you were like hey man
like you've got to be better because you
need to like convert those people in
that room
and then i was like zach my performance
does not determine whether those people
are going to be converted like like i
could do a great job and like
they weren't going to be like oh my god
i don't know if you wrote this
conversation i do
i feel like i was on a street corner um
yeah and so you know like maybe we we
both had it a little bit right because
like could i have been better sure but
like you know i was they were
like okay dude like these dudes weren't
exactly gonna like
you know all of a sudden um uh you know
become yang fans uh on the basis of that
um which must have been endlessly
frustrating for you because you were
like hey is this even working like i'm
getting some people together in a room
for andrew and then he does his thing
and then they don't like just bust out
their rolodexes afterwards
well it was like um i wrote about this
in the book it was like um
we were trying to make andrew appealing
to a certain type of audience
you know these democratic donors and
they already had 29 other options and we
were doing the impossible and we were
out of left field all these things and
so what we we ended up
it was probably that conversation that
flipped it we're like we got to stop
doing this
we got to find something that works
better and we need to instead of
bringing
a certain type of audience we need to
find the audience
that likes our certain type of candidate
we need to bring we need to find the
audience that already loves who andrew
is and the way we found them um
was it started with podcasts um but it
really was the internet it was podcasts
eventually sam harris especially joe
rogan but it was reddit it was amas
it was instagram lives it was it was
just the it was just finding the people
finding the masses going to the people
instead of the elites with the money
um which sounds so cheesy yeah but
that's what we did
essentially what we did well in a way it
brings us back to this podcast man
it's one reason why i love this podcast
so much
uh podcasts really were our genesis
our birthing ground uh like the way we
developed
any kind of a following um for the
presidential campaign um i love podcasts
for that reason i love podcast generally
because most time you have like a human
conversation
with a person and like it's a certain
kind of exchange
um and so this podcast has been
a real source of strength and comfort
and learning and community for me there
have been any number of times when i had
a conversation with someone
and it became a chapter in a book or a
policy
in some cases or
like a new line of thinking and argument
that i make
um and so there have been a number of
things that
uh that have been tied together over the
last number of years
it's been the campaigns and then
reading and writing uh and the podcast
and conversations uh and reflection
you know like that like this podcast
many many
times has been an environment where i
would
realize something for the first time
because i was saying it out loud to
someone
um so it's funny when we reflect on
the the momentum that the campaign ended
up developing
really was because of the sam harris
podcast was the first major one
and the sam harris podcast i say this in
my book you might as well
we were booked to speak at the wingding
in
2018
because of sam harris uh
because one of the organizers of the
wingding was the same harris fan and
listener
and then uh we got invited and i
remember
you being so happy when we got invited
to the wingding
in 2018 uh wait you were not that three
like i gotta go up to cedar
rapids and do what is this i mean you
were like fine you're like look man you
gotta bite into this iowa thing and it's
gonna be golden
oh the other funny thing too and this
happened we had a running joke too with
zach for a while
he's like hey you're going to go in this
big iowa trip it's going to be great
you're going to speak it's the biggest
deal ever and i'm not going to be there
like that they were like like the first
couple of iowa trips where for some
reason that guy because my brother's
waiting for the wingdings yeah
yeah i know obviously i had zero issues
no yeah you didn't know the issues at
all but i was bummed i was pretty fun
[Music]
for me yeah was there one
other trip that there was something
similar i missed a bunch
yeah i had like another um either family
thing or something
it was a running joke after that that i
just like hated iowa would never go
that was the thing but you i don't think
anyone else had the joke but you would
be like oh yeah
i can't make it again i gotta go figure
is that gonna be an iowa all right
it wasn't true i ended up going out yeah
i know of course we all spent a lot of
time in iowa yeah
and i i i really have uh
like a warm spot in my heart for uh iowa
i
hope they feel the same way um i did
until i couldn't count the votes
that was frustrating um well that's just
the iowa democratic party
it's a bad process and apparently the
dnc uh had a hand in that i mean the dnc
made some last-minute
requests and whatnot uh which in some
ways the microcosm of the problems that
we face which is that you have these
institutions who
uh you know make demands and then
uh have and then whoever is responsible
for it on the ground floor has a hard
time delivering i mean that that's
actually
that's pretty much a reasonable sum of
the problems that we have
so i don't blame iowa for that is all
i'm saying it's like uh you know
um and i also
will say that the most nervous i've been
for a speech maybe
my entire adult life was the best man
speech i gave my brother's wedding
so when when you talk about your
brother's wedding and having you
like uh you know obviously that that's
like the most important thing that
so nerve-racking is to do someone who
you speak for a living generally
speaking like you fence for america even
at a certain point you were you know
singing for your supper all day uh
i've done musical theater in a cappella
and performed you know usually a lot of
speaking i was at ubs i was
the problem with being best man quick
aside is that
let's everybody knows you're giving the
speech
if you've been a wedding and there's a
bad best man speech it's never great
it's always kind of sucks the energy out
of the room and
everybody will come up to you throughout
the wedding
and the rehearsal dinner and they will
say the following you're ready for your
speech
you're nervous are you nervous and like
after the 20th person in all of your
friends in your like immediate circle
has said that to you you're like well i
wasn't nervous
until you know everyone i know and love
has asked me if i'm nervous
maybe i should be nervous um but then
when you nail it and you said this for
you like you're going to be nervous as
hell but when you nail it
and it's a friendly crowd so it's easier
to know than at least people will tell
you you sucked um
but when you nail it you'll feel like
the man because everybody will also who
have said ask if you're nervous will
congratulate you and that's also cool
too
and i and i and you did nail it and i'm
sure you still
are like on cloud nine about it because
that's what happened great yeah
you know yeah well what's funny is and
this is something that uh also
you and i like sometimes you know
putting heads over a little bit
you'd be like andrew this is it this
is the speech you're gonna do it and i
was like zach there's gonna be another
like thus each
you know like 14 days later like i
really cannot
like read to this um but when you talk
about like the the speech it is the best
band speech because your brother
uh hopefully only gets married once um
and in my case
uh my brother nailed his best man speech
when i got married
uh x years ago and so i felt so
much pressure to deliver her
and so you know again like you said like
i do a fair amount of speaking so you
assume i'm gonna be good and
you know i officiated my cousin's
wedding and i gave like a speech there
and like i did not prepare a win i'm
sorry
you know my cousin i mean it was it was
fine i feel like it was great i was just
like i'll be
fine but my brother's best man's speech
i was
like i really have to nail this and
prepare interest so i understood
uh and i understood uh you know that
that you had something more important
very much more important because you
know anything that like quote unquote
big that was happening in the
presidential
campaign i was like yeah that'll be
another big thing you know like uh you
know x days later
fast forward to 2020 uh and we
we suspend the campaign in february new
hampshire which was like an incredibly
difficult time i know people we skipped
a lot of stuff uh but
don't worry zach wrote a book about it
which i'll talk about again later like i
wrote a book about it
um so that there'll be a lot more in
terms of the campaign nitty gritty
uh but fast forward to 2020 i end up
ending the campaign which was very very
difficult i felt like i was letting a
lot of people down
uh and that
there was still all this energy around
me
and the movement and so we quickly
started humanity forward which started
out as a ubi
organization and then became a cash
relief organization
when covent hit so we gave a million
dollars away in the bronx
uh to a thousand families and then an
additional eight million dollars to
people around the country
we got money out before the government
did way faster than
we were one of the first organs to get
organizations to catch anybody i
remember that
well we were trying to set an example i
mean that was my thing i was like let me
see if i can
uh do this and then get enough press so
that the government will feel like oh we
should do it too
i we didn't get that much press for
humanity forwards cash giveaways
uh but that you know we did get cash
leap out of congress
and then we spent the next number of
months actively lobbying congress
to uh include cash relief in the next
bill i personally talked to dozens of
legislators on both sides of the aisle
and humanity forward we were jokingly
called the people's lobby
where there's this onion headline that
you can feel free to look up all right
total aside but
it's really some of the funniest [ __ ]
that came out over the presidential
did you just google the onion andrew
yang there is some
hysterical stuff it's really really
funny about like you know me
um being a robot me being like uh you
know terminator from the future
like you know all this stuff is very
very funny but there was an onion
headline
uh that said you know the american
people hire lobbyists to represent their
interests and then there's a guy in a
suit being like i'm here to represent
the american people so that they they
can actually get something done
um so that that headline really stuck
with me and that's what humanity forward
kind of became it became the cash relief
lobby in the people's lobby
uh so that happened all through 2020
and we were down in georgia helping to
win the senate and i'm
so pumped that john ossoff and reverend
warnock won those races
uh we helped raise almost three million
dollars for
uh community or organizers uh
people like stacey abrams and natasha
people give you [ __ ] on that we're like
oh the work was being done on the ground
of course it was being done on the
ground before we got there we went and
helped sometimes we fundraised sometimes
we knocked on doors we had no we've done
a ton like you couldn't have there was
no such thing as not enough hands on
deck in that place
uh yeah and you saw that before now i
mean shoot like you know
like and and we you know we help fund
some of these organizations activities
on the ground so you know love them
yeah but it is weird man it is weird
that someone would uh somehow
uh be territorial about that stuff yeah
we want so we've got all of this
we're not taking credit yeah we had all
this energy
and then we um looked at and
saw that new york city uh
needed something um and i decided to run
for mayor with your help um
and uh you and i lived in new york we
met in new york
um when did you arrive in new york snack
2010
in july it was july 4th weekend for a
call
so yeah you grew up in connecticut but
you grew up far enough away where you
grew up in like
i grew up like hartford so i was like i
came here and it was like i went to
bubba gum shrimp or carmine
and saw like whatever tkts was selling
cheap
on broadway um i thought times square
was new york growing up
um and i've since learned that it's not
anywhere close to the case
although you live close to times square
um i do live close to times square
yeah but i oh i have something
i probably should get you shouldn't give
this away but i i you don't know this
uh so we were driving around and we we
drove by madame tussauds the other day
yeah yeah it's open okay uh come to new
york visit anyway
um uh so uh i said to
um the team i was like i totally want to
go to madame tussauds and just stand
there and act like a wac speaker
[Laughter]
and uh wait wait because these jokes in
the car were like
people were like you're not gonna be
able to was like oh i guarantee i can
feel something all i have to do is stand
there still for a little while and then
like someone will just be like
it's totally gonna work you can do it
yeah i've been here since 96
uh and it's been fascinating
experiencing the city
uh in a different way uh this past
number of weeks and months
uh i've been reflecting on this race
uh and the journey and you know in a way
i wanted this conversation to be a
little bit about the beginning
and then uh something of a punctuation
mark and nothing's really the end
in in this world and this is one of the
things that happened i didn't tell you
this zach but this is what happened to
me
i was meeting with a religious leader
and the people around him were talking
about
my presidential run and then this
religious leader said to me
uh andrew you know what that
presidential campaign was
an introduction to you
and i i heard that and i was like well
that's really profound
uh given at the time i was like well
this is the greatest thing i've ever
done so that's that
but he was suggesting that i have like
all of this activism ahead of me
um and certainly it took a bit of time
for me to realize
that you know the presidential campaign
uh was going to be
a story but then you know we're still
alive the next day
and uh we still see the problems
and there are all these people around
us that care about our ability to move
society forward and now
we have a much greater capacity to make
a difference
than the vast vast majority of other
people so
let's do it let's go for it you know
whatever it is
uh and one of the things that's happened
to me
this probably happened to you too zach
um so sometimes people ask me how the
heck i ever got the audacity to run for
president
um and part of it was that you march
around and you meet enough people
where you're like okay there is no
mysterious cavalry
of super awesome people that are going
to come yeah there is no cavalry yeah
like
like at some point you realize there is
no cavalry that you know it's going to
be us or nobody
like when you get older you realize you
are the cavalry and either you're going
to mount up or you're not
uh and so now that i have
um some things to work with and a
following and a public profile all this
like if you were to line up folks who
are as
capable of having an impact in some way
uh as you and me like now
i mean if you rewind to 2017 uh you
could be like well there's a pretty long
ass list of people you know because you
joined us two random dudes yeah
um and then now we have a lot of the
assets and resources where
if we decided to do something people
would notice or take it seriously from
day one
um it is a different position there are
times when i miss
being the person who is just going to be
ignored or ridiculed
uh you know like like now uh you know
like you're much more noteworthy
um there's like a a degree of attention
that
we didn't have back in 2018 uh you know
to the earlier point of like you could
just do things and you know like the
entire thing was trying to
gain notice um but if you now make a
list of the people i could do something
positive uh and
make it stick you know like the list is
pretty
short at least you know i mean not to
you know i don't want to like
yeah yeah see that's a list of the
people besides the people that were like
us
that are on some list that we used to be
on um
but yeah the list is short yes um yeah
and so now
you know like the obligation to do
something positive
um is even higher and stronger
um so i i so i'm i'm so
uh grateful to you zach again uh the
presidential campaign never would have
come close to achieving as much as it
did without you
uh and no i i hope everyone's listening
to this knows that
um one of the problems in our society
today
is that you attribute a lot of success
just to
you know an individual like in this case
let's call it me and one of the
frustrations i have is that people
say it's like oh andrew's like a big
idea guy and you and i both know that
like you know there was so much grinding
and execution and operation
in order for me to get anywhere near any
place where someone would
uh you know call you an idea guys
yeah yeah no you know what i mean it's
you know like evelyn says too it's like
andrew's like 20 ideas and then like 80
trying to
get [ __ ] done um but like that they get
stuff done i mean it's been you really
you know like because you were the
operator and i became the
um the athlete performer uh and
and it's still the case for me now where
like i'm
still the athlete performer right now i
mean i try and get my
myself into the operational zone um
and i still have that mindset i mean
happily like every once in a while
you know i was like hey guys like xyz um
like i enjoy that stuff uh but
you know super grateful to you zach i
mean that like whatever happens over
this next number of days
uh like we are just getting started i
mean these are all
kind of arcs um in the midst of like
this
mega arc you know like the mega arc of
our
lives really because you know it's like
again like i'm gonna be alive tomorrow
my kids are
still gonna need us to try and do
something positive with this world the
world
is not going well i mean i don't know if
people have the sense like you know when
i was running for president everyone's
like oh
like you know chicken little sky is
falling like doom and gloom and then you
know it's like
you know now you look up you're like
holy [ __ ]
it's like um i i don't know whether i
i think people feel acutely now that
things are not going well
i don't know if that i don't know if
that's right um
so so the themes are we still have a ton
of work to do
uh never would have been in this
position without you and a lot of other
people
uh like you but you know you're singular
in this regard zach
uh and uh you know there's so much ahead
well thank you andrew i've been feeling
mutual and look there were a lot of
people behind the scenes on this
campaign that
you know we got to ride their wave of
work and hustle and that sort of thing
um
i will say so a couple things one a two
thing set one is um
i remember before i joined
i remember i had this dream i was like
um
you know what happens if we fail i was
like well at the end of the day if we
fail
we were still right like this is like
the world is transforming when you talk
about it
um and then like what happens if
everybody hates you and him i was like
well
that would probably mean success because
the reason they have an opinion is
because of the work we did
you know um and that's why i always
respected you like i will be the
sacrificial lamb
for these ideas because people will yeah
totally i was willing to be like it's
all right
yeah um before we decided to run
um in new york after you know after the
georgia election
i put together like a deck a quick like
powerpoint presentation for andrew
and i was like pros and cons of like
your options
um and i remember
we were doing some cool stuff for the
production company you had the podcast
you were on cnn
and i remember i remember saying like
look you could be a great ideas guy and
like talking head
forever if you want and uh you've got a
good gig and you get better and i
remember you said
very clearly like that's not an option
we're not taking this
movement and making it
like a cash out like fun career like as
a pundit like we have to take this
movement and solve problems so like
take that off the table immediately and
uh
it was a good reminder of one thing's
right about the book is like
it's in it's in seven habits of highly
effective people like or i think it is
it's uh uh yeah it's like the main
things keep the main thing the main
thing um
like focus then and you were very very
good at
um and i try to be too like focusing on
what matters you're like no
it doesn't matter what we're talking
about on cnn like it matters
uh where we take this country and we
have to lead it so
um that was the one of the biggest
reasons why we went back into the fray
so quickly because it's like this is
this is the movement um our home was on
fire if you recall
like kobe was disastrous and we were
looking at who was gonna lead this
um and it's been you know people feel
like things are opening
up again the weather's got um and crime
is a big issue nationally
um but you still in addition to crime
you still have
major major economic challenges you know
um that your ideas are needed
anyway um yeah you refuse to be the
talking head the rest of your life i
always respect that well thanks man um
yeah we we're trying to improve people's
lives trying to solve
very very significant problems now i'm
so
proud of the good that we've done i'm so
proud of everyone who's listening to
this who supported us thank you
i hope you're proud of the good we've
done i mean if you had to try and
measure it you could measure it in
billions of dollars that went to human
beings yeah
for yeah um
and we are just getting started um i i
know
sometimes it's not always clear what the
path looks like
but i i do have a vision for what we
need to do
i'm still on the path i'm still fighting
zack's still fighting oh yeah we're
gonna put down the sword yet
too young you're too young yeah
everyone's still evelyn's fighting
evelyn is fighting more than she ever
has recently which has been
which is a lot but um yeah i think she's
yeah evelyn's been even more of a
superstar
um so i i hope the people that have been
with us
like i i hope you stay with us uh you
know
zach and i love you i love you i
appreciate the heck out of you
um yet you've been
uh more than anyone could have ever
expected or asked
uh they're just so grateful and
still fired up still still working still
trying to
make things better for people love you
man
can't wait for this book to come out um
so do you have a pub date
generally i think it's going to be
dependent on yours i think it's if
you're november i think i'm like
february to may
range a couple months after holy cow
look at this everyone
not like look at this so so so i i have
a book that's going to come out toward
the end of this year
and it looks like zach's book is going
to follow because his publisher
is hoping my book does well
[Laughter]
and then his book will do even better um
so uh thank you everyone uh
love you all and uh you know
and uh looking forward to sharing more
of these stories with you
like i've read some of zach's book and
it's awesome um i i have a
book that i'm very proud of uh but yeah
we're still working still fighting
absolutely if you're part of this
this is a journey man and it's not dying
when there's a draw no matter what we do
um we're not going anywhere so i
appreciate all of you as well
thank you andrew let's go shock the
world let's do it
[Music]
you